6200 aktive corona fälle haben wir
derzeit in deutschland und immer wieder
steht die frage im raum werden uns die
urlaubsrückkehrer eine zweite welle
bringen jetzt gibt es zwei neue corona
hotspots am wolfgangsee in österreich
hat man angst vor einem neuen ischgl
denn hier gibt es 44 neue fälle
bei den meisten soll es sich um
praktikantin in tourismusbetrieben
handeln und auch in deutschland gibt es
in einen neuen corona hotspot im
bayrischen mamming haben sich in einem
landwirtschaftlichen betrieb 174
erntehelfer infiziert der gesamte
betrieb steht unter quarantäne und wird
von einem sicherheitsdienst überwacht in
manning ist jetzt mein kollege hannes
kohlmaier vor ort alles was gibt es dort
für neue entwicklungen ja bisher hat es
den landkreis dingolfing-landau nicht
besonders schlimm erwischt um die 300
fälle
seit dem ausbruch der pandemie jetzt am
wochenende uhren 474 480 menschen die
größtenteils erntehelfer hier hinter mir
auf dem bauernhof jetzt gerade unter
quarantäne auch die familie übrigens und
elf feste mitarbeiter dort die
wirtschaften hier 500 hektar vor allem
gurken bisschen noch erdbeeren und man
merkt schon anhand der busse die herum
stehen es ist das echt eine
massenveranstaltung
die werden mit doppel gelenkbusse nähe
zu den fällen in ganz niederbayern
gefahren zum abernten und das
klinikkonzept offensichtlich war nicht
ganz so wie sie es die bayerische
staatsregierung hier vorstellt die
ministerin gesundheitsministerin hummel
hat auch leichte vorwürfe den bauern
gemacht
offensichtlich dürfen nur bis zu drei
leute jeweils in einem container
übernachten und auch die sanitärräume
müssen in gruppen eingeteilt werden und
diese einteilung hat offensichtlich
nicht geklappt es ist zu einer
vermischung gekommen und dadurch jetzt
zum ausbruch sieben leute habt ihr am
freitag krank gemeldet dann wurde der
gesamte betrieb getestet und wie gesagt
bei mindestens 174 liegt auch eine
infektion vor und jetzt fahrt über die
nächsten tage ab minister remmel hat
angekündigt auch andere betriebe bei den
erntehelfern zu testen um festzustellen
inwieweit hier das problem weiterhin
besteht im moment stehen ja alle cara
unter quarantäne und der ganze betrieb
muss bewacht werden wie geht es da es
weiter und vor allem wie ist die
stimmung unter den betroffenen
sie läuft bis sie laufen über den beruf
mit masken natürlich ab und zu läuft
auch mal jemand in einem türkisen
overall mit einer lanze der
offensichtlich die die unterkünfte
desinfiziert also das ist eine einzige
person im krankenhaus die anderen sind
entweder hier liegen in den containern
oder laufen frei herum haben keine
symptome werden hier auch versorgt am
ort es gibt hier auch so einen kleinen
laden wo die leute einkaufen können
dennoch hat man immer wieder natürlich
leute hier im dorf gesehen beim bdk oder
im wirtshaus ein paar meter weiter und
da ist natürlich die sorge auch im dorf
das sich auch andere dorfbewohner wir
sprechen hier von darauf mit 3200
einwohnern auch angesteckt haben könnten
hätte denn auch die unterbringung der
erntehelfer hier eine rolle
ja natürlich die vermischung hat
sicherlich auch in den bussen
stattgefunden hinter mir sieht man so
ein mit dem die erntehelfer zu den
feldern fahren aber auch gerade die
durchmischung der sanitärräume also sind
immer 78 personen die immer gleichzeitig
ist nur diese gruppe in sanitärraum
darauf und da hat eben diese sogenannte
vermischung gegeben und offensichtlich
wurde das nicht gründlich überwacht das
nur die gruppen die wirklich in den
sanitärräumen dürfen auch wirklich da
sind oder waren andere dabei hannes
vielen herzlichen dank für deine
einschätzungen